Andy why don't you tell us about the
best erection of your life or does
anyone else have any remarkable
erections
HR have some rules against talking about
this kind of stuff marinates are it's a
joke I can't do anything about anything
for five years I've held my instincts in
check because I wanted to be made
manager
maybe it's time for me to just let that
thought go
it's kind of painful but it's also
freeing in a way
now it's all about my instincts
hey Dwight Stanley
one way or another you are going to come
with me to make this sale pass can you
just let me out of here before whatever
comes next don't worry it's just a bull
tranquilizer nothing to be alarmed about
it's just a man pointing a bull
tranquilizer at a co-worker the whites
you do not learn do you for threat to be
credible
no you didn't I'm sick of you
it's all right Andy approved it you're a
good guy me too
Michael appears to be gay too
and yet he is my friend
I guess I do have a gay friend
you know what I'm going to raise the
stakes
you know wait I want you to watch this
and I want you to burn this into your
brains
because this is an image
man I want you people to remember for a
long time to come whenever you come into
the office I want you to think about
this
we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
I did it
see
I'm still here
we're all still here
oh come on Dwight come on man
okay everybody what's up
earlier today Stanley sassed me and Toby
gave me some suggestions on how to
discipline him they did not work
obviously because they were stupid so I
am now going to fake fire him
what does that mean it's like a mock
execution that's not again yes it is a
good idea it's the only possible
solution I have left well you can
actually fire him no okay
why are you telling us this because I
want you to behave as if I'm actually
firing him Oscar okay Michael if you
hadn't told us this then we would have
thought that you were actually firing
I'm not firing him I'm not I need you to
act like I am firing him just what I'm
going to do is I'm going to pretend that
I'm firing him and I need you to act
like I am firing him do you get that do
you get it I'm teaching him a lesson he
needs to learn humility all right that's
all I'm okay here he comes let's just
player
Stanley may I talk to you for a second
Stanley Hudson
you are fired
are you serious
I am serious we are all serious
you are fired like a heart attack you're
firing me over three words have you lost
your mind do you think I'm gonna let you
do this to me I've watched you screw up
this office for 10 years and I'm filing
a lawsuit and I'm going to tell them
about every stupid thing you've ever
done up in this office all right okay
you know what
now you know how I feel
this was a fake firing
lesson learned good work everybody very
nice
so I'm not fired that's it
and uh
do you have anything to say to me oh yes
I do
you are out of your damn little
peace-sized mind what is wrong with you
do you have any sense at all do you have
any idea how to run an office every day
you do something stupider than you did
the day before and I think there's no
possible way he can top that but what do
you do you find a way damn it to top it
you are professional idiot hey stop it
okay everybody out who yeah everybody
except Stanley
Jim would you prefer a nature metaphor
or a sexual metaphor oh God nature when
two animals are having sex one of them
is communicating a message to the other
nothing is this isn't very helpful
you're going to want to hear the sexual
metaphor was that not that oh life is
sex and all sex is competition and there
are no rules to that game
that wasn't so perverted now was it is
that it no that wasn't bad I was working
in finance and I got involved in some
Insider training so I spent a little
time in the clink
that is awesome
I had Martin explain to me three times
what he got arrested for because
an awful lot like what I do here every
day
you know what
I love Phyllis
you know what else
I think she is gorgeous I think she is
an incredibly incredibly attractive
person
come here come here come on come on you
don't have to worry I'm not worried HR
you know what the only thing I am
worried about is getting a boner
good work today everybody
yes it is true I Michael Scott am
signing up with an online dating service
thousands of people have done it and I
am going to do it I need a username
and I have a great one
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
it's okay guys I can handle this
everybody can go home we're here for the
show Michael
you're just a bunch of voyeurs are you
eating popcorn it has almost no calories
you ready
yes
you have to keep your hands down I know
all right
oh God Michael yeah
he's down put your hands in your pocket
okay
pam pam
I'm really sorry I'm sorry
what are you sorry for so many things I
don't know it's hard to choose how about
for dating my mom maybe that's dumping
her on her birthday yes
okay just
don't ever date a member of my family
again
okay
so the record your mom came on to me
holy crap
are you okay no you're okay
feel better no you were right
oh hey hey no time to chat well we were
just looking for Ryan so he's not here
hey you looking for me oh yeah we were
we were just gonna say hi so hey
no you weren't no we weren't you wanted
to have sex in my office nope definitely
not it's it's it's cool just um try to
put everything back where you found it
uh text me when you're finished up I'll
be out here hey you don't have to
that was so embarrassing I'm gonna die
yeah that was really rough